all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
on what is going on in my life so today
I my trainer gives me these at the gym
and I really enjoy them
today I am going to be telling you about
my escapades with volleyball England
right now
so
um
my friends were playing in a volleyball
tournament
and I played in this tournament last
year but this year I signed up too late
I couldn't get in it whatever
and I heard that dudes were playing in
this tournament
now they might have been there last year
but I just wasn't paying attention so
maybe they were maybe they weren't
um but I wanted to go see so I went to
this tournament
I saw a bunch of dudes playing
um
and I I took interviews
I got girls opinions a lot of people
were afraid to say anything right
because they don't want to get in
trouble uh and I also got people that
agreed with them playing's opinions so I
really was interviewing both sides
everyone that I interviewed I had
expressed permission to interview
um
so
then what did I do next oh and I also
got footage of them playing just you
know is it fair
I I don't know so
today
um so I've been going back and forth
with volleyball England about a tweet
they're saying my tweet was transphobic
I've been going back and forth I I
recently identified as trans as a trans
um man so you know I because they said
transphobic is
a tweet that um
anything like anything transphob I asked
them what is transphobic and they said
anything a trans person feels is
transphobic so lucky for them I recently
identified as a guy
um my pronouns are the same I'm not
gonna dress any different but I do feel
inside that I am a dude so now
um but for some reason they haven't gone
back to me on that okay whatever going
back and forth about a tweet today I
receive a message hi it's the tournament
director I understand you are filming
and interviewing at the tournament this
weekend in order to publish anything you
need explicit permission from me at the
University which this is a bit funny
because girls
um film all the time at tournaments I
see them filming footage and everybody I
interviewed I had express permission and
everybody I interviewed I interviewed
outside of the tournament
uh because it was so loud in there
but okay
um it was so it's like why do they get
in the middle of it when this is between
me and the people and I can blur out
their faces whatever
um as you didn't obtain this you have
not you do not have permission to use
these recordings from the event there
were minors no there were not there were
no miners in my videos and vulnerable
adults on the site so I'm like what is a
vulnerable adult you know what
vulnerable vulnerable adults are
me and the other women that are forced
to play against these men I'm like you
don't know who you're talking to
respectfully in order okay okay as you
didn't obtain this um you do not have
permission these were minors and
vulnerable adults on sites please
comment contact Yasin at uel and get all
the clear to publish also I would like
to know what was recorded and what your
intentions to public publish are you do
not yet have permission to Publix do you
have an email that I can contact you on
so let's I'm gonna call this number and
see how it goes
what the
yes okay what
okay let me let me try this it's not
letting me go let's
okay
do I need to add a
I don't understand British phones
the system's busy please
all right so
I okay I guess I'm gonna send an email
what should I send an email you know I'm
gonna try this the real way right so I'm
gonna see all right permission hi
what should I say to this person
I am emailing you
because
I was told I need to receive
to get permission and the crazy thing is
this is Semi-Pro they don't even pay me
they don't even pay me I'm like this is
too much okay
and my issue my issue is we think we're
signing up for a woman's tournament and
now we we play with men if you want to
do a co-ed tournament fine but
the way it is now somebody's gonna get
hurt
and there's women that want to say
things about this but they're afraid to
speak out
um Okay so
I was told I need to get permission
to film for a video
I recently
did interviews
at the school video I'm doing
on trans women I'm just going to tell
them in sports
I interviewed
people their opinions on it
at the tournament
everyone I think this is stupid anyway I
interviewed
gave me permission to post
whatever
all right I sent it now
um
and the crazy thing is I spoke to this
tournament director I I'm like you know
this stuff is wrong and I'm gonna go
through too I I talked about this on
Twitter already but basically
I was accused of transphobia me a trans
man it's like the audacity so what they
did and I have the videos from this so I
tweeted this I said a bunch of a bunch
of my volleyball teammates played in a
tournament today and they were trans
people in it they've made it to England
no now this dude emails me and says I
see you remember volleyball England has
a transgender policy which you agreed to
abide by through your membership you
have breached this policy thus also
breaching the volleyball England code of
conduct I have been appointed to
investigate this manner I ask that you
respond to the alleged breach within
seven days by the 20th I think today is
the 20th actually it's the 21st okay
So I responded what did I breach and
they said um note the final paragraph in
the policy I said what is defined as a
transphobic Behavior this is what I was
talking about earlier well because I
read their policy volleyball England
welcomes and supports all coaches
officials and volunteers who identify as
transgender and does not tolerate any
transphobic Behavior if the behavior and
action is a volleyball England's member
employee are offensive towards any trans
person volleyball England will
investigate the matter and with where
appropriate discipline the club or
individual according to the code of
conduct and disciplinary policies so
this person says if you are able so I
said what is what is what is transphobic
I'm I'm okay so he said if if you're
able to see the tweet from the
perspective of trans person you will
feel that will you feel the organization
was welcoming
um so I said so it's based on how the
transgender person feels and I'd like to
clarify the policy because volleyball
England if you look up their policy on
this it's very vague they say during
regular season they don't allow trans
people in
but then we're at the tournament when I
asked the director of the tournament he
said that trans people were in the
League this year I guess I didn't notice
they're getting good
so I said also I would like to clarify
the policy as I'm not certain to what
I'm reading during the regular season
biological men cannot play in women's
division but an offices but an
off-season tournaments they can and then
he said if this is a relevant issue
perhaps you should put consider putting
it in your response they won't answer me
they won't answer me I said I'm trying
to clarify the policy so I can give you
a response I don't want to misquote you
and then he just kept saying feel free
to put anything you think is relevant in
the response I said I certainly will but
again just asking for some clarification
so I can understand what I did and how
it will be handled if a transphobic
tweet is defined as if you were able to
see it from the perspective of a trans
person would you feel the organization
is welcoming which trans people will be
making the decision on if they feel my
tweet is unwelcoming is there a board of
trans people that come together and
decide what is offensive and what is not
also I'd like to clarify the policy of
trans women competing in women's sports
for volleyball England this would be
very helpful so I can make sure I know
what I'm responding to and how it'll be
handled
Pearl if your lack of understanding is
the transgender policy is relevant I
suggest you consider putting that in
your response I've attached the so why
this should be an easy question where
are the trans people allowed to play
where because if you guys look up the
actual volleyball England policy it's
vague and off season and they say
they're not allowed in regular season
but they won't even clarify that so I
said hi Gordon I have actually decided
to identify as a man recently my
pronouns are officially your majesty I
am a trans person and would like to
weigh in on the Tweet as it is not
offensive as it is true in a matter of
fact welcoming trans people like myself
did make it to England and are playing
in all the all all nations tournament I
would like to recommend myself to be the
head of the board of transgender people
thank you for your consideration I would
like to hear the outcome of this in
person please maybe we can even meet to
discuss representation for people like
myself
I just hope they if you guys hear
snoring it's my dog many of you so my
question is okay
if there's nothing to hide
why
oh I got a response I got a response
from volleyball England they said
it's the university policy and the
policy of events like this
but it's never enforced
it's never enforced except when it's an
agenda that they don't like
so
look I I'm a I like volleyball England
I've had a good time playing here but my
issue is when I have friends coming to
me that they're in a tournament
and now they're getting hurt
from dudes
you know I had one friend said she hurt
her finger because she was blocking
against a dude you know that's when I
have a problem so I I just feel like if
you're doing nothing wrong
you know there's nothing to hide so okay
so my question is
so
this is University policy who knows
maybe I'm wrong maybe I shouldn't be
ranting about this on the internet
but I will continue to rant about this
because it's wrong and I don't give a
okay I don't give a if they
want to kick me out of England they want
to say whatever
um
wrong is wrong and you will not convince
me to treat men like women
you will not convince me you will not
convince me to live in delusion and
pretend there's nothing wrong with this
like I can't say anything about
my friends and me having to share locker
rooms with these people having to share
the gym and play against these people
you know
I have nothing against trans people but
they shouldn't they shouldn't be in our
locker room so they shouldn't be in our
Sports so
maybe I'm crazy let me know in the
comments I don't know
um like the video and I'll I'll keep you
guys posted on if I get permission to
post this stuff uh like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time